dramatic declines halted stock trading
on Wall Street yesterday for the second
time this week the Dow closed down 10%
that is the worst day on Wall Street
since 1987 and over the past three weeks
the Dow went from a record high to a
downward bear market in just 19 days
that is he fastest slide since 1931
Gregg Hippias chief economics
commentator at The Wall Street Journal
and he joins us now Gregg good morning
certainly a lot of economics to comment
on on the moment sure is yeah
are we in recession territory very
likely yes I mean the shutdowns and
activity that you're seeing all across
the economy are gonna create a big hole
in the economy in the month of March
possibly April so economists now think
that is probably a 50% probability we're
going into recession but given how fast
things are moving I think likely we will
have a recession I think the main
question right now is how severe is it
and how long does it last and those are
things that we're really not certain
about and they will depend a lot on how
effective the government response will
be is there anything more that the
Federal Reserve can do at this point the
Federal Reserve has done all it can do
but frankly interest rates are already
quite low they're almost at zero and low
interest rates really can't help combat
a virus or encourage frightened people
like to go to the theater most of the
effort here has to come from other parts
of government mostly Congress in the
White House
in terms of providing aid to those who
are directly affected by the crisis and
putting more cash into the hands of
people who are still prepared to spend
the markets were clearly not calmed by
the President's speech the other day
what do they want to hear from the White
House well I think that one of the
issues we've been dealing with all along
is that the policy response including
from the President and from other folks
overseas has often been confused and
there's been misleading information
that's understandable because nobody
really knows how far the epidemic is
going to be but I think markets really
want to here is first of all a coherent
and coordinated strategy rather than
political bickering they want to hear
that the things that we know need to be
done like more sick pay like enhanced
unemployment insurance are going to
happen and they would like to see like
the real firepower of this government
really come to bear on it even though
the Federal Reserve doesn't have much
ammunition this country can borrow a lot
of money and do a lot of stimulus
interest rates are below 1% this is the
kind of time the federal government
needs to use those low borrowing
for the help of the economy well let's
talk about some of the firepower that
Congress has the president has called on
Congress to pass a payroll holiday
payroll tax holiday what would that be
and what effect could might it have so
individuals and employee employees
together contribute about 10 to 15
percent of their income as payroll tax
so that could be lowered and that would
increase take-home pay there's a couple
of problems with that if you're
unemployed you're not gonna benefit
because you're not paying any payroll
tax I think the other problem is that
it's sort of like is doled out over a
full year as you get each paycheck but
we know that the economy is coming now
so there's a case to be made that the
priority should be getting cash into
people's hands now and we know how to do
that President Bush did that in 2008
very quickly and there are proposals
that there right now that Congress could
very quickly for example just say let's
send $1,000 to every adult out there
here's a silver lining though the
Treasury secretary announced that he's
going to extend the tax deadline so
folks individual taxpayers including
small businesses hey they get some more
times that help it does help because one
of the things that's happening right now
is many businesses especially small
businesses they're going through it a
cash flow crunch suddenly sales are not
coming in the door right but they still
have payroll to me they still have taxes
to pay they still have suppliers right
this is a time when banks and the IRS
need to sort of like make accommodations
and see if there are ways to help them
get through this period because we know
as bad as things are right now it's not
gonna last forever you mentioned a
moment ago sending $1,000 to every
American the government could do that it
could sure as I said we the government
did something very somewhere in 2008 all
right
standing by yeah oh thank you
Greg Greg yep thank you